it was the first time that boris johnson
had spoken to mps about the fine that he
received during the easter recess one of
a number of fines handed out to senior
figures in downing street by the
metropolitan police as part of their
ongoing investigation into allegations
of rule breaches specifically parties in
downing street during periods of covet
lockdown he repeated the public apology
he'd made at the time
acknowledging people's hurt and
disappointment saying they had a right
to expect more from their leaders from
the very people who made those rules in
the first place but did he think he'd
actually done anything wrong
let me also say
not by way
of mitigation
or excuse me
but purely
purely because it explains my previous
words in this house
that it did not occur to me then or
subsequently
that a gathering in the cabinet room
just before a vital meeting on covet
strategy
could amount
to a breach of the rules
i repeat
that was my
mistake
and i apologize for it
unreservedly
that will infuriate many of his critics
including mps within his own party of
course who will likely continue to feel
that boris johnson is failing to give
this issue the gravity it deserves and
that he continues to seek to lessen to
minimize to trivialize his own
misconduct
here was the leader of the opposition
labour party kia stammer
what a joke
even now
as the latest merely mouthed apology
stumbles out of one side of his mouth
a new set of deflections and distortions
pour from the other
peril still lies ahead for boris johnson
of course
there remains the likelihood that more
fines will be handed out by the
metropolitan police as its investigation
continues indeed boris johnson himself
may yet receive more fines and the local
elections in may loom at which the
conservative party is expected to fare
badly if it does
that could be held up as the public's
judgment of boris johnson and at that
point his position could be tenuous
indeed